la crisis en la cadena de suministro
podría dejar a miles de británicos sin
regalos de navidad unos 50.000
contenedores están bloqueados en el
mayor puerto comercial de reino unido
felixstowe que maneja alrededor del 40%
de las cargas de mercancías que entran y
salen de la isla
creo que habrá algunos transtornos de
estas navidades como resultado de la
escasez de camiones pero los minoristas
son realmente expertos en asegurarse de
que dan prioridad a las cosas que la
gente quiere
a poco menos de dos meses de las
festividades navideñas el periodo más
activo para las empresas navieras y
puertos los retrasos en las entregas a
las tiendas de productos importados son
evidentes en reino unido donde el 90% de
las importaciones llegan por mar las
causas del congestionamiento portuario
son múltiples el break sheet la pandemia
y la falta de conductores de vehículos
pesados que han obligado a desviar
grandes buques a puertos de países
vecinos
hay un enorme retraso en las entregas
creadas por la escasez de conductores el
break sit y una serie de otras cosas que
acaban de crear la tormenta perfecta
sin embargo el co presidente del partido
conservador gobernante animó británicos
a comprar con normalidad
es evidente que existe un problema sobre
todo con los conductores de vehículos
pesados y no sólo aquí sino en toda
europa polonia eeuu e incluso china por
eso hemos tomado medidas para
solucionarlo por ejemplo más formación
5000 plazas más para la formación de
conductores de vehículos pesados
flexibilizando el proceso estamos
trabajando en estos desafíos
reino unido tiene una escasez de unos
100.000 camioneros que obligó a las
autoridades a ofrecer cinco mil visados
temporales para trabajadores extranjeros